actually for this trailer to be that's
right I'm dusting off the Star Wars
curtain I had as a wee Star Wars lad
that I now rock as a cape because Star
Wars makes me feel like a child again
because we have our first trailer for
rogue one a Star Wars story I woke up
that's all I have to do you all rock I
just go on Twitter and I'm like yeah rug
one trailers up so many requests which I
get by the way but this trailer is rad
it starts out the rebellion get has
Felicity Jones she's in cuffs so she's
obviously captured don't think she's
part of the rebellion yet she's not part
of the Empire I just think she's a rogue
no like yeah here's your file you do a
lot of illegal [ __ ] and she's like this
is a rebellion I rebelled pretty sure
that's her sales pitch for bringing me
on boards yeah I initially thought that
she was already a rebel oh she was
getting reprimanded the thing that makes
me think otherwise is the fact that
they're like ah you forged Imperial
documents I don't know why that would be
a negative on her rap sheet maybe they
just hate it when you forged their
enemies documents so she's an odd rebel
and getting recruited or she's a rubble
getting reprimanded point is the only
thing that matters is after this scene
she is a rebel and Mon Mothma is like
there's a weapons test that's inevitable
we need to know what this weapon is and
how to destroy it this trailer has great
tone it's really gritty really dark
really boots on the ground spy stuff in
the Star Wars universe and it really
shows you what they're planning with
Star Wars which is it's not just a core
trilogy anymore there's more out there
man there are more stories to tell him
the story of the rebels who initially
got the Death Star plans it's an awesome
story why not tell that and I personally
love it when the alarm comes on the blue
boy reminded me of Prometheus a bit but
remember that's the original co G
Imperial alarm from the original trilogy
let me stress that because it's not some
people like well I guess they found the
new boils down to fact for some trailers
now it's from Star Wars I see why it's
in the trailer and I'm pretty sure this
is an exclusively Star Wars thing might
be some other blouse out there but the
blinds have been around for a while and
trailers but I'm really interested to
see some characters man Forest Whitaker
comes out he starts monologuing you see
the Grand Admiral dick I don't know who
that
love to know look I just don't know yet
which is funny because I mean you just
know the inevitable fate of pretty much
everybody on both sides imperial and
rebellion we know where all these people
are gonna go man they're gonna die I
only say that because nobody except Mon
Mothma is in the original trilogy so a
lot of people are gonna die
sorry Grand Admiral dick unless a lot of
them are on other missions at other
places at the time of the original
trilogy in which case we have more
spin-offs coming which would be really
cool to the force Whitaker's all like
but what do you do if they catch you
what will you do break you you see
Morgan from The Walking Dead while
swinging a stick like no life is
precious I love that shot of all of them
running on the battlefield and those
walkers are above them just blasting
that there's this comic book store that
I frequent it's called Gabby's Olympic
cards and comics down in Olympia
Washington and Gabi's husband was like
one thing I'm looking forward to is this
director shows scale really well he did
that in Godzilla so I'm looking forward
to seeing this Death Star and being like
oh my god that's enormous kind of got
that with the Star Destroyers around the
Death Star in the trailer but where you
really see it is that battlefield with
the 8080 walkers yes they're called 8080
s not at-at just saying man that's it's
8080 my initials are JJ you know you
call me JJ you don't call me just but a
really interesting part of this trailers
from Forest Whitaker's like if you
continue to fight what will you become
and it shows Felicity Jones in an
imperial outfit now she could just be
spying maybe that's the outfit she wears
when she goes and invades and gets the
plans for the Death Star maybe or maybe
they just offer her a better price who
knows it being so close to the original
trilogy I feel like I'm standing to my
statement where everyone dies and I
think she's just wearing that Imperial
outfit to get in there and get the Death
Star plans no this is gonna be sweet
this is awesome this is Star Wars the
curtain cape is back and this is the
first time we've seen a trailer that
shows the universe expanding it shows
them doing branches man roads that lead
out other stories to tell it's not just
the core trilogy if this is the first
trailer for the first movie that's gonna
do that this is pretty solid opening
boots on the ground supply ship with
Star Wars but my question to you is what
did you think about the trailer whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more